[Music]
Macaulay Culkin wants babies with
girlfriend Brenda song at least that's
what he told Joe Rogan on his podcast
the Joe Rogan experience yeah I'm gonna
make some babies you know stuff so get
this one so this one's a good one so you
know I'm Papa gonna put some babies in
here looking a little bit I mean we
definitely been practicing but ya know
ya know this one yeah I'm gonna have a
gonna have some pretty babies she's a
she's Asian so I'm gonna have like yeah
I'm gonna have little tiny little Asian
babies yeah it's nice yeah it's gonna be
adorable
door above a bunch of Shawn linens
running around the house that's what I'm
looking for both Macaulay and Brenda
have been pretty private about their
relationship she kept it hush-hush
even when et knew they were dating last
fall
what do you say to all the romance
speculation between you and Macaulay
right now I don't like to talk about
your personal life but you're not
denying it well McCully is definitely
opening up about it now and opening up
about a job he turned down three times a
role on the Big Bang Theory though they
may pursue it forever mayne for a Big
Bang Theory
oh Christ lucky at that and I said like
no I said like nah cuz it was kind of
like the way that pitch was was kinda
just like all right these two like
astrophysicist nerds and then a pretty
girl lives with them yikes like you know
and like that that was the pitch like
yeah it was just like yeah and they're
like oh we're gonna get some real like
physicist like you don't do the Matt and
I should look at no I said I'm cool like
thanks and then they came back at me
again and I said no no like I'm like
again flattered but like no and then
like then they came back at me again and
like even my manager was like twisting
my arm come on I want the pieces listen
I'd have hundreds of millions of dollars
right now if I did that gig at the same
time I be bashing my head against the
wall
[Music]
[Applause]